Best-selling author, Jack Spencer, finally
released a new book today that
confirms his place in the one-hit wonder aisle.
Daddy!
Do you guys have to leave?
We're just going on a grown-up vacation.
We used to do it all the time.
You guys are gonna love this place, trust me.
Who are you?
Calm down.
Nate must've double-booked us.
Nate?
Hey, welcome to Green Acres.
Would you like a tour of the land?
Yes.
You should stay.
We should go.
You are not staying here for us.
You're staying for Magic Mike.
Hello, Theroux.
Hello, Tarzan.
We are supposed to be saving our marriage,
but all you have done is be dude-downer.
Stop!
Stop it!
Hey!
This is a violent free zone den!
Jack!
Amanda!
You guys look totally made for glamping.
Glamping?
Is that like a thing?
Totally!
We keep doing that!